all right today we're talking fortnite
and we have to guess are these
characters in fortnight jinx i'm gonna
go with no no yes she's not in i gotta
say no jinx and vi they're both in there
and it's the only one i'm like 100
confident about i'm gonna go no really
what is she doing there does ryan know
she's the
baby oh because of arcane
walter white my gut says no there is no
way walter white from breaking bad is in
fortnite advertising a meth cooking show
to kids that's a good point i didn't
even think about the drugs
i don't hear some little kid going jesse
let's cook like there's no way
oh god
montclair jackets i feel like for some
reason they are uh
you know my vibe with that i'm going to
go with no but i hope to god i'm wrong
it's too mad to be made up
oh yeah liz listen it's just iconic oh
my god i felt the vibe check real fast
oh my god this is the best game ever